give some context the art is from notes
to strangers it's a guy called Andy leak
on Instagram where even in the words and
what resonated with me there is rest as
hard not as much like we perceive hard
as time still but it's balanced and it's
not saying you have to have an equal
amount of time of rest to work but what
you do within that time that matters as
well because you hear the one like the
classic one is you know work hard play
harder that kind of thing but that
doesn't take into account the kind of
rest and and rest isn't just sitting
there doing nothing rest can also be
what we talked about daylight reflection
awareness like getting to know yourself
more and working out how you can then
work more efficiently